do whatever the [ __ ] you want forget
whatever tattoos you want just make sure
they mean something at least what's up
Duke you this big 14 and I'd like to see
some alright fifteen sixteen fourteen
[Music]
yeah I grew up on 14th Street put my
friends made a group called 1400 and the
number always stuck with me I always see
it everywhere I go it's an angel behind
the numbers and jelly know if I live and
breathe something I might as well show
everybody what I live and breathe
it's my brain call from shore block 800
it's actually two rival gangs that don't
[ __ ] with each other but I make them
like this
I got into Atlanta this [ __ ] right night
for my finger it's a knife it's a knife
barbed wire I feel like they're my own
hey love stars
it is just a brand I was thinking of
like something catchy to come up with so
I made up love scars and I got a tattoo
before the song was even a game it's a
scar my brother he had passed away in a
car accident they say his face is like
scar right so I just got a scar loved
scholars they say TR 666 cuz Wayne got
him I thought there was always cool they
excited his [ __ ] eye they tried out
my attic I grew up my whole family has
tattoos my mom's had a trippin right
across her [ __ ] arm and she got my
place over somewhere my dad got my phase
okay it's oops revenge that's my brother
that passed away cuz I'm his revenge
I said members on the end I got its had
it when I was with X I used to live with
my mind so I got it like I got it like
the majin buu kind of him because you
know I like that was anime stars
Oh
dirt Naruto and seven deadly sins
it just says 14800 is basically saying
[ __ ] is 48 so this is the infinity
symbol I'm saying just an infinite loop
the red is negative energy and the black
is positive energy so I got like
different for teens and [ __ ]
going into infinity and all they're just
symbolizing me back up to infinity all
that [ __ ] matters the positive and
negative energy you need it people
actually think these is upside down
crosses I don't know why not really
that's a women something 14 - just
symbolize girls that have been through
love scars you know 14 just just for
good it's a logo that says demons that
play you know the kids that play [ __ ]
it's just demon Zeppelin
demons at play
that's Bomberman dressed up as a Freddy
Krueger I used to play bomberman in the
key and then I just got it looking like
Freddy Krueger cuz my friends they like
Elm Street and I don't know at Omaha but
it's like an Indian and Irish tomahawk
because I'm Indy and they're Irish and
black iris Pike at the end Irish lad was
like any issue with feathers at the 14th
only got blood all over in the shoes I
would never tap my ass at my chest and
then on my tablet right here the one
that's about to be right here is gonna
be the Grim Reaper but with a burgundy
rag on his head I mean really the only
thing that really hurt was like this and
that was from like it being right on my
bone other than that none of the
textures really hurt do whatever the
[ __ ] you want forget whatever tattoos
you want just make sure they mean
something at least